est ce que quelqu'un l'a reconnu
d'office c'est là cécile vignes diesel
est ce que vous êtes le sosie officiel
de contrôle ou à je déteste cette blague
on vous l'a dit non mais alors
maintenant d'ailleurs oui je peux pas le
dire mais je te dirai à un truc après
portant sur quant aux beaux gosses à
poser des questions oui oui bien sûr
maxime est ce que vous aimez vous la
réponse est non vous aimez vous énerver
j'ai envie de te dire que de temps en
temps oui
jean mi est ce que vous mettez parfois
des lunettes de soleil ah oui l'emmène à
celui qu'ont les questions pertinentes
ivg est ce que vous faites des stores
nos combats je pense que vous allez
trouver un alors justement pour vous
aider à trouver un indice s'il vous
plaît en régie
pour trouver de qui il s'agit premier
indice donc sur cette personne
est un monsieur est ce que vous êtes un
sanglant faut pas trop me chauffe étions
trop de chauffer alors jeune homme est
ce que vous êtes le sosie officiel de
vincent lagaf non est ce que vous allez
d'éléments dissidents réfugiés ont
taillé pour saluer lundi sa deuxième
indice l'olympia l'olympia donc il a
peut-être fait quelque chose devant
l'olympia j vous êtes un ringard je me
souvenais on a poussé mon
film mais c'est pas mal est ce que vous
êtes messagerie vocale
de
vous n'êtes pas un sosie me souviens
bien vocal boîte bien un gars aient bien
regardé mon gars c'est bien connu on
avait déjà fait la france a un
incroyable talent mais qu'elle s'est
déjà bien ça ça c'est pas bien alors
dernier à dix dernières années je crois
que jean michel
gentil je crois avoir vu la vidéo
monsieur ses nerfs ces maires de l'ain
pierre disant qu'ils sont les brokers
les mauvais rockeur et les fautes assez
grande parodie parle de john x était
ravi jean michel maire il s'agit des 10
le quartier
aujourd'hui bras moi j'ai remis alors
souvenez-vous c'était en 2009 et 10
l'avait fait le buzz avec sa vidéo le
rock dans lesquelles il livre une
analyse très personnelle justement sur
la musique rock
freddie mercury c'est quand même le sol
qu'il allait faire des courses garder sa
cape
il n'y a plus il ya plus de rap il ya
plus de rancoeur ya plus leur coeur pour
les années c'est pas calogero là où je
sais pas quoi la whitney houston ce pas
cependant durant j'ai passe alors le rox
sait pas que l'europe c'est arrive pour
friendfeed a et u s'est passé à
l'arraché c'est simple tu prends des
risques la peur il ya là il ferait mieux
de faire du blues
c'est pas dur le blues as tu te mets
dans un champ tu pries
cette vidéo et les torsions du mineur et
il ya beaucoup de gens qui se sont
demandé si c'était une vraie vidéo moi
je crois que c'était vrai mais moi quand
je les sors si je savais rien et alors
c'était vrai ou pas c'était vrai quoi
c'était une vraie vidéo vous êtes un
comédien et coups de gueule mais c'est
un comédien parce que vous avez fait
plusieurs vidéos après voilà en
backstage vous étiez backstage nom aussi
dans un autre concert on vous voit moi
j'adore génial c'est un génie un génie
fautes passées mais je suis d'accord non
je suis d'accord c'est vrai c'est
extrêmement beau l'âme beaucoup mais
jenny j'ai dit que s'ils n'ont aussi
c'est bientôt vous êtes mieux maintenant
aller voter je me suis un peu calmé
effectivement alors c'est cette vidéo
qui a lancé votre carrière hédi
ben oui bien sûr c'est le cac a explosé
en 2009 et après j'ai bricolé d'autres
trucs où j'ai effectivement pas chez moi
j'en sors une ou deux par an depuis
depuis bas depuis dix ans puis ce buzz
vous avez donc sorti plus de 40 vidéos
c'est quoi une quarantaine c'est ça une
quarantaine c'est quoi les sujets qui
vous inspirent aujourd'hui à aujourd'hui
balaj en est une qui sort dans quelques
jours sur les jeunes
j'ai traité un truc qui est assez sympa
je me suis bien marré c'est sur les
jeunes et la et la drogue enfin les
jeunes qui se défoncent ans dans leurs
soirées donc ça je me suis bien marré ça
va sortir bientôt ça et celui d'après
c'est
sur les télés sur les smartphones donc
c'est dit c'est dit qu'il ya son
smartphone et qui t'expliquent les
nouvelles technologies à travers son
smartphone gilles c'est toujours de
l'humour ou parfois voulait dénoncer les
choses non non non non non il n'y a pas
de nom il n'y a pas de clairement ya pas
de dénonciation de messages on rappelle
évidemment que l' usage de la drogue est
interdite maxime est dit est ce que vous
vivez aujourd'hui de vos vidéos ou vous
avez un un autre job
h au caire non je n'en sais rien aux
manchots fait ce jeu tu vois tu vois
bien que je suis pas sur les plateaux
télé je fais pas de scène donc
clairement je peux pas en vivre donc moi
je fais ça un peu comme un amusement
mais je fais régulièrement donc le but
c'est quand même d'en sortir je pas 2,3
par an quoi voilà pour vous avez donc
quand on vous amuser ouais je le fais je
le fais je fais plaisir sérieusement
aussi quoi mais je je je suis obligé de
bosser un peu à côté fiona une question
au président pour tourner vos vidéos
comme ça vous avez une vraie équipe de
production tu voyais pas rond chez des
gens qui sont dans le dans le métier
quoi j'ai des vrais cadreur et des vrais
saint dié j'ai des gens qui sont qu'ils
savent faire ça bien comme il faudrait
et pourquoi par exemple ce soit ou été
de même de soleil vous avait promis
d'être conway c'est ça c'est ça ouais
ouais non mais vraiment je veux pas
qu'on me reconnaisse avec vous a
beaucoup reconnu quand la vidéo à buzz
et ça fait d'éminents c'est pour
maintenant en fait ah ouais ouais c'est
maintenant je sais pas pourquoi c'est
souvent c'est quand je parle dans la rue
quand je marque quand je marche dans la
rue avec je je je parlais les gens se
retournent et à tuer la même intonation
aujourd'hui des vidéos qui est normal
personnage vous pourriez accentue extra
mais ça c'est qu'en fait c'est vous et
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui des vidéos
elles font 10 20 30 millions de vues
facilement là ça date de 2009 14
millions d'euros c'était énorme en 2019
donc que je comprends qu'on vous a
reconnu il paraît que vous vendez des
t-shirts et des préservatifs à votre
effigie ah oui tiens j'en ai d'ailleurs
merci georges tarnais emmené un simple
merci oui beau cadeau ça marche bien
je les porte pas pouvoir déranger les
vents j'essaie de les vendre suffira
merci je sais merci merci je suis juste
derrière toi merci c'est simple pour lui
cela
tient pour le jour j